- Now to the latest trend
that's sweeping the internet.
- So called NFT.
- [Reporter] They're now
selling for huge bucks.
69 million dollars.
- So what's behind this latest craze?
- That is the question to ask.
- Okay, so there's some
super strange stuff
happening online right now,
and I need to tell you about it.
First, look at this tweet.
The first tweet ever tweeted
in the history of Twitter.
The tweet was by Jack Dorsey.
- I'm one of the co-founders of Twitter.
- And this tweet was
somehow just purchased
for $2,915,835.47.
- (laughing) You serious?
- And it's not just a tweet.
Just last month a single jpeg
sold for 69 million dollars.
The NBA is selling little
moments of basketball games
for hundreds of thousands of dollars.
This is all sorts of digital things
that people are purchasing
a version of them
for lots of money.
There are three simple letters
that you need to understand
to understand what's going on here.
Those letters are NFT.
- Now to the latest trend
that's sweeping the internet.
- What is exactly is an NFT?
- So called NFT.
- Do you all in the chat
understand what an NFT is?
- Does that stand for not safe for work?
What does this mean?
- Why would you pay for an NFT
when you can look at it for free?
- Is this a gigantic bubble
just waiting to burst?
- I believe in this space
with my whole heart.
- I'm just fascinated by it, all of it.
- This story is much bigger than
a $600,000 cat gif.
Or a three million dollar tweet.
It's a story about human psychology
and how the way we
value things is shifting
because of technology.
A technology that some people think
may revolutionize our society,
while at the same time
accelerating the climate disaster.
It's really nuts, it's all
of these things together
and I wanna explain it
to you, so let's do this.
♪ Now what the hells an NFT ♪
♪ Apparently cryptocurrency ♪
♪ Everyone's making some money ♪
- [Announcer] Oh that was insane
officially insane Lebron James.
- NFT stands for non fungible token.
Okay, there it is, that's the explanation.
Non fungible token, makes sense right?
The video's over now.
No, one of my issues with this topic
is that people throw around
things like blockchain,
crypto art, ledger, NFT,
and they just expect me to understand
what they're talking about, and I didn't.
Okay, I'm gonna talk about
a Tesla for a second.
Customized by Unplugged Performance
to be the most unique and
high quality Tesla there is.
Oh and it's not just a Tesla,
it's also $20,000.
You can enter for a
chance to win the Tesla
and $20,000 by going to
Omaze.com/JohnnyHarris.
When you donate $10 or more,
your donation goes to
support two non-profits.
501C3 is the first one.
They are an organization that seeks
to mobilize the next generation
to fight climate change
by creating a global community
that embraces low carbon culture.
The other one is called Give Power
which seeks to give clean drinkable water
to the 2.2 billion people around the world
who do not have safe
access to clean water.
The non-profit uses its
deep solar expertise
to power and provide clean
water, food security,
and light to regions around the world.
So to potentially win a Tesla and $20,000,
and to support these organizations
go to Omaze.com/JohnnyHarris
to find out more.
So, fungible,
let's talk about the word fungible.
It's this very specific word
that economists use,
it has a very precise definition.
I wanna use a different word
for fungible for a second.
Let's just use the word replaceable.
Non-fungible means non-replaceable,
you can't replace it, there's
only one of them, it's unique.
Non fungible.
Let me give you an example
of something I feel very strongly about.
Let's say you want to
buy an orange jacket.
This is really absurd,
I've actually never counted these before.
- Stop it, get some help.
- You wanna buy an orange
jacket from Uni Qlo.
You go on the internet,
and a jacket costs $39.
If you purchase one of
these jackets for $39,
you don't care what specific
jacket they send to you,
they're gonna make thousands
of jackets in your size,
send them to stores, send them to people,
and they will send one to you,
you don't care which one it is.
The jacket is fungible, it's replaceable.
As long as you get one
that's identical to the rest,
it's worth the same to you,
they're interchangeable.
However, let's talk about
one Uni Qlo orange jacket
that has been with me
for a very long time.
This is the original,
and for those of you who don't know
I sort of have a strange
attachment to this jacket.
I just love it, I love the color,
I feel like an identity with this thing.
And it's sort of starting to disintegrate,
but I love it.
And I kind of fell in love.
This jacket is not replaceable.
If I went onto the website and paid $39
for a Uni Qlo orange jacket
that was this exact same model,
it would not be this jacket.
This jacket is non-fungible.
It is the only one on
the planet that exists.
It has emotional value.
It has significance.
It is a very valuable
thing because it is scarce.
There is only one of them,
it's valuable to me at least.
And I kind of fell in love.
Okay, we can put these down for a second.
Everything in our economy
is one or the other,
fungible or non-fungible.
A sack or rice is fungible,
you just want a sack of rice,
you don't care which one it is.
The Mona Lisa, non-fungible,
there's only one.
Unsurprisingly, non-fungible things
are way more valuable
than fungible things.
To that's the NF in NFT, non-fungible.
Now let's talk about
the T, which is token.
This is a very internet-y word.
And to explain this, I
have to explain something
I have avoided explaining
for a very long time,
the blockchain.
Luckily, there's a way to understand this,
and I'm going to make it
as painless as possible.
Let's say I want to buy
three slices of pizza
from my friend Anna.
She charges me six dollars
for these three slices.
I don't use cash anymore,
so I pull out my debit card, my bank card,
and I swipe on her little terminal.
As soon as I swipe this card
a message is sent to my bank
and it says hey, Johnny, who
has an account at your bank
wants to spend six dollars on pizza,
and that money needs to go to Anna's bank.
This is like the bread and
butter of what a bank does,
all day, they document every transaction
that comes in from all their customers,
they send out money to the other banks,
and at the end of the day
they have a tally of all the money
that went out of your
account and into your account
and they can give you a number.
They can say based on all
of these transactions,
you have $50 in your bank account.
And so when that request
comes in as I swipe my card
my bank is like okay,
based on all of your transactions
you have $50 in your account,
I can send six dollars
to Anna's bank, approved.
And they approve the transaction.
Once that money comes into Anna's bank,
Anna's bank is doing the same thing.
They're like oh cool, she had $80
and now she has $86,
and they add it to her record.
More and more your money is
just a number on a screen.
It's the result of a
bunch of transactions.
You don't barter with physical things,
you don't use cash as much.
So the bank keeping meticulous records
of every transaction
becomes really important.
We trust the bank to do this correctly.
So thank you banks.
Banks and other middle men
have been keeping stuff
like this running smoothly
for centuries.
I mean kind of smoothly.
- [Reporter] The NASDAQ,
everything and more
has been completely wiped out.
- [Reporter] It was the
worst day on Wall Street.
- What in the world is
happening on Wall Street?
- There have been a few bumps in the road.
With the rise of the internet,
people started to wonder.
Is there a way that we
could do this same thing,
coordinate this same transaction
of transfer of money between
two people without the bank?
The result is a very clever
concept called the blockchain.
The blockchain.
The blockchain fulfills the
same thing the bank was doing,
but instead of doing this
privately on my bank account
and talking to Anna's bank,
all of the transactions
are actually recorded
publicly on the internet.
♪ You're going surfing on the internet ♪
So let's redo this
example in a crypto world.
Anna charges me six crypto coins
for my three slices of pizza.
I go to swipe my proverbial bank card
to say yes, I want to pay you six coins.
Instead of the bank seeing
that request for a transaction
and trying to validate it,
it goes on to this public record
where a bunch of people's computers
all around the world are keeping track
of every single transaction
of everyone always.
If I don't indeed have the
six coins in my account
to pay Anna,
all of the people's computers
who are keeping track of
every single transaction
will notice that there's a discrepancy.
They'll be like whoa whoa whoa dude,
you don't have six coins.
We're looking at every transaction ever
and you don't have six coins.
Your transaction is rejected.
If I do have six coins,
all of the computers
looking at the public record
will see that request for a transaction
and they'll be like yep, approved.
You have six coins and
now Anna has six coins.
And they'll write that transaction
into the public record.
Now Anna having those six extra coins
is now the business of everybody,
everybody now knows that.
The point here is that the group verifies
the legitimacy of every transaction
by keeping an eye on every transaction
to make sure that it adds up.
Okay I'm getting hot at this point,
so I'm taking off my orange jacket.
Okay, so you're wondering
what does the blockchain
and this public record
have anything to do with cat gifs
that sell for $600,000?
Well I'm about to tell you.
So in my pizza example we
talked about blockchain
as a way to verify currency transaction.
I pay you this much, you pay me this much
and everybody knows how much everybody has
because it's all public.
But this is where it starts
to bend my mind a little bit,
what if we apply this to something
that isn't money or currency?
Let's say one day you're
just looking at the ledger
and the ledger's like
Johnny wants to give Anna six coins.
Okay he's got six coins, approved.
And then a transaction comes up
that's like a Malaysian businessman
wants to give three million dollars
worth of coins to Jack Dorsey
in exchange for a little token,
or digital certificate that says
that the tweet is now somehow owned
by the Malaysian businessman.
The only thing that the
blockchain cares about
is does the Malaysian businessman
have three million dollars worth of coins?
And so a bunch of computers
all around the world
look at the whole entire
list of transactions
and say like yeah, this guy has more
than three million dollars
worth of coins, approved.
They approve the transaction,
and now it is written in a public record
that is unalterable
that says that this Malaysian
businessman owns this tweet.
The token has been
transferred to somebody new,
non-fungible token, NFT.
And if there's anything
that gets human psychology
to value something,
it's if an entire group
validates that it's real
and that there's only one of them.
There are tens of thousands
of NFTs of all kinds.
Some music is being given tokens,
lots of art is being minted as tokens
and being bought and sold,
and then of course there's.
- NBA Top Shot.
- Who's taking advantage of this.
- These highlight moments,
these Top Shot moments from
your favorite NBA players
have been turned into non-fungible tokens.
- Jesse made headlines the other day
when he paid $208,000 for
a Lebron James Top Shot.
- It's the weirdest thing.
As soon as humans have enough abundance
to have their basic needs met,
food, shelter, warmth, et cetera,
the next frontier is to create value
in things that have no inherent value.
The value turns into psychological hype.
Excitement around a certain thing.
We've been doing that forever,
I mean the whole art industry is based
on the idea of a bunch of people
deciding that this painting,
this little bit of
canvas and wood and paint
is valuable, and thus it is valuable.
The only different about now
is we now have the technology
to do this in a non-physical way
using this very sophisticated
internet technology
that is maturing very quickly.
Okay, so this is a lot of hype,
and I know you're thinking like cool,
there's a bunch of rich people online
buying and trading digital art,
and there's millions of
dollars worth of cards,
I thought you said that this
was gonna have the potential
to change the world.
And I'm getting there, but first
I need to talk about the crazy
flip side to the NFT fad.
The reality is that the technology
that is the backbone for all of this,
the blockchain stuff that
we've been talking about
relies on the public ledger
thing that I talked about.
That is the sort of heart
and soul conceptually,
but mechanically, like physically
what it relies on is computers
doing a bunch of little calculations
all day and night forever.
These computers aren't real computers,
they don't have any memory,
or screens, or anything.
All they do is just make
little micro-calculations
all day, all night.
Most NFTs are stored on a
blockchain called Ethereum.
And as of now, in early April
2021 when I'm filming this,
the Ethereum blockchain
is using 33 terawatt hours of electricity.
And you're like what's a
terawatt hour of electricity?
That's the same amount of power
as the country of Serbia.
A reminder that generating electricity
usually comes from power plants
that are burning
fossil-fuels, that are putting
carbon into the atmosphere
which is a big freaking problem.
- [Narrator] Facing a manmade
disaster on a global scale.
- The power consumption
of the Ethereum blockchain
is exploding, it quadrupled
in the like eight months,
and it is showing no sign of slowing down.
It is a lot of energy.
And to think that that much energy
is not being used to
like, move people around
or produce things,
it's used to crunch numbers
in a weird computer warehouse somewhere
so that somebody can buy a fake token
of a thing that we only,
oh man, I can't, it's mind blowing.
It's such an ironic moment
where it's like this is all digital,
it's all fake, it's not real,
but it's having deeply real world effects.
I just wanna finish this video now,
talking about what this might mean
for our world going forward.
This is definitely hype,
and that's the whole point.
I mean these speculation
markets are all about hype.
We see this all the time
with new technologies
and new things that
people get excited about.
And they swarm it with their investments
and the price goes up,
and then something happens, for example.
- Come on Uncle Phil,
this is the '90s man.
- What's a web page,
something ducks walk on?
- How nice of you to join us.
- On equal value, so cash
in on today's new economy.
- It's the '90s, it's hammer time.
- In the '90s the internet was taking off
and people were just realizing
that you could make money on the internet.
You could make big
businesses on the internet.
The stock market was
surging, 400% in five years
mainly fueled by so much
hype and excitement around
these new internet companies.
- [Reporter] Break the record
as America's longest boom.
- The new economy, is a boom without end?
- This rise peaked in March of 2000,
and then the bubble burst,
and a lot of these
companies either went under
or completely lost all of
this excitement valuation
that they had.
- Saw it didn't you, it was down some.
- But, did that mean that
the internet went away?
Did that mean that internet
businesses didn't come back?
No, companies went on
to reshape our world.
Right now I think we are probably
in that stage of NFTs.
It's hype, it's novel, it's exciting,
but what it's doing is
it's pushing our minds
to think differently about how we validate
and verify things.
If I buy a house, there is a whole
thick stack of paperwork
and a bunch of middlemen
to make sure that it is very clear
who owns the house,
and how that money gets transferred
from one person to another.
It is a nightmare of an experience.
If suddenly technology
existed that took away
the centralized middle man
and made transactions between people
able to be authenticated, verifiable,
and much smoother, that
could change our world.
I'm not here to say if
the bubble's gonna burst,
or whatever, I don't know.
I just know that this is a crazy moment
where we're getting our
heads around a new technology
and what it means,
and eventually will adapt.
This won't be crazy, this
won't be novel anymore,
prices will go down,
but the technology that
allowed it all to happen
will probably stick around.
(soft music)